Donald Trump made some comments Saturday
night it was definitely a slip-up
regarding Sweden let's watch that first
look at what's happening in Germany you
look at what's happening last night in
Sweden Sweden who would believe this
Sweden they took in large numbers
they're having problems like they never
thought possible mistake I think we can
all agree mmm yeah mistake
now if the media just went and said
that's a mistake there was no incident
in Sweden I'd give you that that'd be
fine but that's not what they did what
they did was they use this to go on and
say so Donald Trump there was no event
in Sweden okay good fair and there's no
problems in Sweden nothing nothing to
see here and they go on and they use it
as a narrative to try and debunk fats
that are coming from obviously the
consider the conservative wing about
Sweden Sweden does have a problem Sweden
has seemed their murder go up over 80
percent in the last decade they've seen
rape go up about 50 percent it is the
rape capital of the West Sweden has a
lot of problems so if the media would
have just stuck to Donald Trump's word
slip and by the way it's really easy to
wait for those just wait for another one
coming on the pike instead they give him
a gift because they're so driven by an
ideological agenda they feel the need to
fight all the battles and they feel the
need to push this sort of propaganda
narrative that Sweden's doing fine just
watch Don Lemon try and argue this is
the guy actually Donald Trump was
referencing when he said last night he
was talking about an interview with this
guy and then here he is with Don Lemon
trying to fact-check him hilarity ensues
where did you get your information and
and did you look at the the official
number it's called bra BR a which is the
keeper of all stats for Sweden sexual
assault from 2006 2015 is up almost 50%
murder 2012 2016 is up I think almost
over 80% yeah now so those are the those
are the real numbers I don't want to be
rude though but are your ears and your
eyes working because the numbers as
we're reading from bra yeah right and
from the the State Department forget I
don't show what you're saying you're
taking those abroad
right here that's his bra yeah yeah hold
on you're classifying this as a
skyrocket that crime is skyrocketing
rapes yeah it's not a skyrocket so you
think you think when when rape is down
in the United States and everywhere else
in Western Europe and then rape is up
50%
that's not skyrocket because of the way
they classified sexual assault in the
United States but it's not sexual
assault in Sweden correct is now under
the rape that's not a little Jew again
the left just the gue Donald Trump GU
the right a gift last night this started
happening riots started breaking out in
Sweden all over the place look at that
of course
trash can fires seem to be a favorite
technique of the deadbeat looter slash
rider now this happened for those who
don't know this happened because there
was a man arrested or they tried to
arrest in the subway in Sweden I'm not
able to find this here they didn't
specify it was a migrant but they didn't
specify if he was Islamic call it a
hunch
and so the reason these people started
riding was because they thought it was
unfair
I guess profiling this is as far as we
know right now at the moment of this
recording they thought it was unfair
profiling from the police toward a
migrant which threw a wrench actually in
the works for the CNN panel they had to
change the most recent slogan to
qur'an's up don't shoot and not to be
confused by the way though that was the
CNN panel not to be confused with with
Chris Cuomo on his show how he reacted
well see for yourself
[Music]
take a breather Chris you don't need to
get that upset yes count to ten you're
the point here is I mean you see this is
Donald Trump misspoke he makes mistakes
and the left is so set on trying to I
don't know if it's the cable news cycle
I don't know if that's 24-hour news
cycle and it's a problem for them but
it's got to get to a point CNN where
it's um it's embarrassing I mean to be
fact-checked and to be proven wrong in
in real time you can't get enough of it
apparently
[Music]
breaking rules lalala will Crowder I'm
Perry Mathison in the wake of President
Donald from scowl surrounding Sweden
we're taking our lives who are on the
ground Swedish correspondent Jimmy Jimmy
what's going on down there yes Perry
thank you being here on the ground I can
tell you that the current rumors
surrounding Sweden are in fact just that
rumors unfortunately put out by the
President of the United States
as you can see Sweden is a very
family-friendly country a booming
economy once once a home to nothing more
than cowardly hockey players and
building bookcases slash sofa beds it's
now a beacon of progress for all fussy
as a matter of fact Perry I saw a meme
on Facebook today which I can semi
corroborate that the crime in the state
of Florida where President Trump
delivered an address today is actually
worse than the country of Sweden thank
you for that valuable information Jimmy
now what's going on there behind you if
there is some kind of collusion
no I think you're that's incorrect
you're simply misinterpreting a man
behind you being little boys which is
cause for concern well that's not that's
not what's happening at all and we
should hold ourselves to higher
standards Perry than to spread
misinformation like that the Swedes are
our passionate people as this is well
known and this is a family get-together
that would be misinterpreted by people
of the American God like a professional
clearly this is not a get together
that's escalated my god those are riots
Jimmy can you confirm any look oh no
don't use that word that word Perry has
an inherently negative connotation which
I would refrain from using Queen is a
it's a booming economy and it'd be a
shame to this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit coms
mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than six dollars a month and
you get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand etched mug oh I just when I
feel it I got a chill like on the inside